we've got a voicemail from the Eggman
about knishes interestingly enough of
prime topic for the Eggman let's take a
listen to what he had to say Dave when
you get a knish at that cool bakery in
Boston and these are round baked ones or
the square fried knishes right I'm
really tired of the round baked ones I
can't even get a square fried condition
in western New York anymore the kind
that the Muslims sell of the street
carts in New York City how come if you
buy a knish a kosher potato food in New
York City it's usually a Muslim guy
telling it's you from a street cart
serious question which line you prefer
not the question about the Muslim
selling this of course Shalom brother
yeah shell on bag man um at Michael's
deli it's not a bakery but it's deli
they have the square knish it's not
fried as far as I know it is baked and
then you flattop it if you order it
there of course then you can take it to
go and then toss it back into the oven I
don't recommend using the microwave
because it will sort of soften it up
yeah I prefer an oven or if you can
flattop it that's really the way to go
but yes they are these square knishes at
Michael's deli
although mamillus delicatessen in
Cambridge Massachusetts does have the
round knishes which I know
Pat's very concerned about finding a
round knish in the Boston area and you
can do it you can do it just so you know
I don't think I've had a condition
before that's I don't have a knish
preference and on that note of deer a
total derailment of the story we will
wrap up the show and speak to you on the
bonus show